In addition to [UNKNOWN] mehta talks about, meta at all talks about services.
Now these are not, services in the sense of services that the, user sees or
even service in the sense of client server. Okay that words,
it's a unit of computational service. These are services that connect or
provides the overall architecture. According to Mehta, it's a service
category that represents the broad interaction role the connector fulfills, and
they lay out four different categories of services including Communication.
That is the transmittal of data. Coordination which is the trans,
transfer of control. Conversion that's when some kind of a translation is
going on, particularly among data formats. Okay? And
Facilitation that is some kind of mediation or operation optimization activity.
And they use the abbreviations, T,O,X and F respectively on,
in their diagrams to abbreviate those particular four categories of services.